[Musica]
non si può più aspettare
spingi dai un respiro ecco le gambe
ancora forza devi uscire anche la testa
eccola la prendo io
20 la 20 la il tubo non passa cioè
un'ostruzione in gola 20 la prova ancora
ecco è passato è viva l'apporto su io
sono quella mamma prematura e vorrei
portarvi oggi la voce di chi è stato
fuori e dentro a una termoculla
affronteremo insieme un doppio dialogo
dove io parlerò con voi e chi è là
dentro parlerà con me là dentro c'è un
grande prematuro questo è un grande e
prematuro pesa 5 131 grammi è lunga 27
cm
il cuore batte ma non respira c'è una
cannuccia che scende fino ai polmoni li
gonfia e sgonfia d'ossigeno e potrebbe
da un momento all'altro soffiare via
punto 1 la realtà uno su dieci nasce
prima 3 su 10 mila così tanto primo ad
essere considerati tecnicamente un
aborto spontaneo anche se vivi cosa vuol
dire così tanto prima prima della 24a
settimana cinque mesi e mezzo la
bottiglietta là dentro è nata alla
23esima la percentuale di sopravvivenza
è molto meno dell'anso di una monetina 3
su 10 la probabilità di sviluppare
disabilità è molto meglio non pensarci
allora ho capito che sono viva per ora
sono rara e per il futuro si vedrà
punto 2
la mansarda la termoculla io la chiamavo
così piccola umida buia e con le tende
sempre chiuse a me mi sembra una capsula
e io ho fatto un viaggio spazio
temporale ne sono sicuro sono arrivata
quattro mesi prima la gravità mi spiace
che la luce mi acceca i suoni mi
assordano ma non sono mica la prima
anche superman è arrivato con una
capsula e allora qual è la mia missione
punto 3 la barriera signore la mia
barriera si apriva era una finestra
l'oblò della termo culla la vuoi vedere
un attimo no la vuoi toccare un attimo
no io lo guardavo ma non vedevo mia
figlia d'altronde non l'avevo sentita
muoversi neppure una volta nella mia
pancia mi costringeva non amare qualcosa
che poteva morire in un istante è una
colpa ah ho capito qual è la mia
missione è dare tutti i giorni degli
schiaffi in faccia la mia mamma finché
non smette di avere quell espressione
catatonica e poi metterla tutta quanta
testa mani e piedi in un secchio e
sommerge la di amore e to home one con
la barba che mi chiami formichina chi
sei
il babbo ti perdono che non era in sala
parto solo perché la prima volta che mi
hai guardato divisa il cervello che non
affrettata a forma di cuore allora anche
batman aveva una spalla e io ho bisogno
di una mano in questa missione che si
chiama mamma punto 4 il parentado
io capisco l'entusiasmo di accogliere
ogni nuovo nato sono fatta così
ma io mi sentivo dire è già nata sei il
mio vicino di casa 50 anni fa è nato
prima l'hanno messo in una scatola da
scarpe e adesso sta benissimo
possiamo venire a trovarla capiamoci a
un ago che da qui arini e mezza al
torace 1 nell ombelico un tubo dritto
nei polmoni uno nello sfondo con una
luce rossa intorno a un piede e la pelle
completamente trasparente che si ulcera
solo a guardarla
no non credo che sopravviverebbe in una
scatola da scarpe ma io dico se una
persona che non avete mai conosciuto
prima viene ricoverata fra la vita e la
morte in un altra gente
mi verrebbe mai in mente di chiedere se
la si può andare a trovare stabile
stabile instabile signora c'è un
infezione generalizzata abbiamo scelto
un antibiotico che arrivi a coprire
anche il cervello cosa ma come 30 minuti
fa stava benino mi sta lasciando
[Musica]
all'appello wolverine capitan america da
apple
ok ricchetti miei non mi sento proprio
in forma
voi ci siete già passati vi hanno già
iniettato delle sostanze super
potenziati e a volte penso che il dolore
sia troppo ho paura di non riuscire a
farcela ma voi ce l'avete fatta
siete diventati più forti di prima date
una mano perché devo continuare a dare
degli schiaffi alla mia mamma e mi tocca
resistere punto 5 i canguri
forse alcuni di voi lo sanno già da
quando il piccolo canguro nasce pesa un
grammo ed è lungo 2 cm percorre come può
alla distanza fra lutero il marsupio e
una volta lì si attacca con la bocca ad
una mammella e non la lascia più per due
o tre mesi
le mamme premature in fondo fanno come
le mamme canguro solo che i loro
cuccioli si attaccano alla terapia
intensiva qualche mese e i loro
cangurini li appoggiano sul torace
si chiama marsupioterapia mi hanno
chiesto se la marsupi a stata una gioia
grande la prima volta che l'ho sentita
qua
volevo squarciare mento razzo ad
infilarsela dentro immediatamente
no decisamente prima è stata un enorme
dolore ma poi lei mi ha toccato
salvandomi l'anima e io le ho detto sì
ogni giorno ma le macchine riallacciano
alla vita come una spina ma tu dove sei
mi serve dove sei tocco dolce a mano
ferma una sul mio capo l'altra sotto i
piedi
sarà il mio confine
mamma e io sarò la tua preghiera
eccoti calmati la senti la macchina che
attaccate ai miei polmoni
suona per chi non le do retta voglio
respirare insieme a te punto 6
le somiglianze e niente quel tubo nei
polmoni non lo si riusciva a togliere
senza non reggeva era un continuo togli
e metti togli e metti un pomeriggio
mentre il dottore era pronta a
ripiantare nella gola la guardava e mi
disse è bella sai ti assomiglia
mi interessa solo che sia viva ma ma
allora mi misurano continuamente la
testa perché piccola la pancia grosse
dall'ombelico esce della roba e mi hanno
detto che presto inizieranno a puntarmi
delle luci negli occhi per capire quanto
sono ceca anche la cosa dei fantastici 4
dead bull e bestia degli ics non sono
esattamente icone di bellezza in ogni
caso io mi sento discretamente [ __ ] e si
te lo assicuro sono viva punto 7
l'azienda bianca quanti di voi hanno
usano un'azienda nel telefono in tasca
in terapia intensiva neonatale le agende
sono bianche non ci sono ore nei giorni
le settimane ci sono solo i complementi
e sul fondo di ogni pagina c'è una linea
rossa in costante stabile stabile
instabile
un pomeriggio qua me l'hanno rianimata
quattro sei dieci volte il cuore in
chino non reggeva c'è un base lino
botallo si chiama che di solito alla
nascita si chiude ma qui era ovviamente
aperto il chirurgo ha detto arriviamo
vicino al cuore e lo chiudiamo con due
bollette le facciamo tanti di interventi
così abbiamo esperienza ma se si rompe
muore
[Musica]
ossigeno per favore ossigeno allora
senti chirurgo ascolta me questo per
assenza da fare perché questa che
annunciano i polmoni da sola non ce la
fa più e poi vedrai che la togliamo ho
capito che posso morire ma non mi hai
mica ha detto una cosa nuova
e poi la mia mamma ormai l'ho quasi
conquistata o solo una richiesta le
graffette o luminose come il cuore di
iron man o di adamantio come lo
scheletro di wolverine
se si può ossigeno per favore punto 8
l'abbraccio credetemi non è questione di
fiducia
semmai di fede fede nell'energia che
gira perché le mani lavorano sempre
sicure e guidate da cervelli sapienti e
le macchine sono instancabili
infallibili
eppure nella notte e thermocool e
scompaiono nel nell'inutile
nell'inconsapevolezza del silenzio e non
tornano più
per questo tutte le volte che ho
abbracciato una mamma l'ho fatto per un
secondo in più nel desiderio di essere
io a voler abbracciare nella speranza di
non dover mai essere abbracciata mamma
doomsday è sceso una volta sola per le
strade di metropolis ma bussa ogni
giorno ai nostri oblò siamo guerrieri si
ma al suo cospetto davanti al giorno del
giudizio
l'intera justice league e perfino
superman sono caduti di quelli che ci
lasciano non ricordiamo solo il nome e i
dettagli ma portiamo la forza nel cuore
e se dovesse aprire sarà con quella che
lo sfiderò punto 9 la pancia piena
signore in sala qual è la prima cosa che
chiedete alla maestra quando andate a
prendere i cuccioli ascoli na ha
mangiato la mamma italiana ha bisogno di
sapere che la panza del proprio cucciolo
è sempre piena e finché quel pancino si
riempiva con un tubicino fino allo
stomaco io dormivo più serena
una mattina quel tuo vicino non c'era
più e la fame quale fame di chi lasciami
dormire lo sai molto bene che mentre
dormo il mio cervellino si potenzia non
sono pigra
mi sto allenando non hai imparato niente
da magneto doctor strange e per falso
rics punto 10 la notizia signora è ora
di andare tutti a casa a casa si
decidiamo una data di dimissione di
missione
ma se fino a ieri aveva bisogno di
ossigeno non si sveglia mai per mangiare
al biberon diventa blu perché va in
apnea al seno si impegna da matti è ma
non su c'è nulla come posso farla
crescere dai mamma non fare la tragica
non sono mica dimagrita e poi a casa
mica li perde mie superpoteri sarà solo
tutto un po più normale poi non senti
che casino gli allarmi qui se mi
prometti che a casa c'è un po più di
silenzio andiamo a casa
signori io porto mia figlia nel cervello
nell'egoismo dell'amore del tempo dei
farmaci e dentro di me non la sento ma
c'è io la porto nelle orecchie nel
terrore di non sentire più il suo cuore
nelle unghie infilate nei palmi ogni
notte nei lividi da farmaci liquidi
porto mia figlia nello stomaco buio
razionale di una termoculla nella gola
perché sento i suoi tubi nella mia e nei
polmoni perché lì si blocca l'area
quando il dolore manda in black out il
cervello e il cuore
io porto mia figlia sulla pelle del
torace perché respiri con me sul seno
perché ogni giorno consegnerò il mio
legame di latte e con spalle più leggere
quando anche solo 15 grammi di tubo in
meno
incidono sulla bilancia io la porto
sulle mani al fasciatoio perché li posso
sentire i suoi calci sulla mia pancia da
fuori e poi a casa dove la paura deforma
lo specchio del cuore
guardarci il mondo attraverso io lo
porto sulle ginocchia ad ogni pasto
perché è più facile vedere quando
diventa blu e poi lei e sulla mia bocca
fra i baci e sorrisi le parole anche in
questo momento e negli occhi ogni
istante in cui non è con me io la
indosso con la fascia al marsupio il mei
tai le braccia preziosamente vestite
l'una dell'altra cuore a cuore occhio
occhi ma lei cammina da sempre due passi
avanti a me lasciandomi briciole di
energia a mostrare la strada signore
porto mia figlia addosso anche se è lei
che ha sempre portato me
[Applauso]